Aaron Thompson you're here sorry it took
five minutes for us to get around to
introducing you and you've just done a
live stream over on the under set for
Rainbow six siege I want to talk about
the sort of the grand history of the
rainbow six franchise going back to 1998
but before we get into that what do you
think of siege now that you've sort of
you Chris plated up this event a couple
of weeks back now you've played it with
gen pop kind of in this closed alpha and
stay tuned for we're giving away codes
what do you think about really succeeds
now you played it with like a bunch of
random I mean to be fair I think the
first couple hours of today was just
pretty much the JV teams kind of
scrimmaging and learning how to play in
the game yeah not necessarily indicative
of what it's gonna be halfway through
the week when people actually start
getting five-man teams together and
communicating that being said I don't
think they can ever rely on people
actually talking that's a lot of when we
ran into this morning they're really
gonna have to work on those mechanics
for example we're talking about how you
know evolve has a certain amount of
spotting that works and less portal has
the look in time you know even like the
old Vegas series had the mark and like
go kind of yeah true under the door
style yeah so they're gonna have to do
something with the lack of talking and
it can't just be oh we're just gonna
assume people are gonna talk cuz you
were playing on PC is that right yeah
yeah I guess it's a problem with the
next-gen consoles as well our current
gen is that for some of them that the
mic packs were bundled in as well as so
like people just really kind of I guess
they had versions that didn't have the
mic I think the Kinect one if you got
that do you got a headset even if people
do have mics man I mean you can't count
on them to to talk or to want to talk or
to be playing an environment when they
can talk so yeah you they need to have
something like that we asked them about
it when we were there they said there
may be working on something but it does
feel a little crazy currently in the
closed alpha it's you know some people
are talking but the audio and for the
most part for me was really muddled so
it's tough to hear and so you're just
kind of like well go with this guy and
maybe we'll do something complementary
together and you sort of try to observe
what your teammates are doing and sort
of have a loose plan and I think like
Erin said as they're only two maps
and so as people get to learn the layout
get to learn what are effective
strategies that the whole level of the
game will improve and then well that's
the idea yeah you hope that will happen
but especially it currently in the
closed off that you can't squat up oh
you're not like Aaron and I can't go
into a match together right and that's a
whole different experience because you
were able to like plot ahead of time
we're able to you know scout and sort of
coordinate stuff and that is a lot of
the fun of sort of teaming up and
figuring out ways to dismantle the
situation actually interestingly enough
you know it's developed up in Montreal
and all of the people we're also
speaking French on the server even you
know it's a closed closed alpha but like
our French is kind of rusty yeah so yeah
like maybe having the game have
contextual call-outs will be better
where the actual characters themselves
call out what you're seeing just things
that get away from players having to
memorize what everything's called and
articulate what it is to other players
outside of the communication snafus
obviously this is a outfit outfit and
build of the game so it's super early
and have you guys been sort of playing
around with the destructibility with the
weapons have you learned any interesting
middle sort of tactics to flanking runs
with sledge the attacker
he's got the hammer all like normally to
breach through a wall and destroy yep
like set up your pad get to see if this
dance thing yeah oh him he's just like
oh but and it blows up and so if you
like I had a few times where I just like
ran through the cargo air or the rooftop
crawlspace of the plane and came around
and just bought my way through walls and
totally destroyed dudes you kill people
with the sledgehammer no yeah you can we
haven't actually done it success either
because it's like as soon as you see
someone you want to shoot him real quick
cuz bullets kill you super quickly right
game that kinda sucks though yeah and
but like to do that you need Intel so
having your drone avail like looking at
security cameras still super important
my favorite moment from the stream this
morning was literally when Chris got
backed into a corner was like oh my god
I'm trapped and then he was like oh wait
no you can just go through this wall
it's just like changing your whole
mentality that like it this is not an
obstacle to me anymore I can get out
just go through it that's actually I
heard there's some sort of there's like
a weapon that shoots lucky bombs and
walls
explode but you guys figured out like
this new way of using it we used it to
so it was there was an indestructible
wall and there was somebody had put down
Castle I think it is had put down a
barrier and so we fired it into the wall
next the unbreachable wall next to the
barrier and it blew sideways almost like
a throwing a claymore mine yelling its
equivalent of a grenade but like you you
know it basically blew out behind the
cover and kill the dudes excellent yeah
there's a lot of stuff still to learn
about a Rainbow six siege yeah like you
can't shoot through airplane windows
don't even try it yes it's good for
Intel seems legit I guess if it's like
Air Force One maybe that's the thing who
knows and that's siege that's coming at
a later this year but I don't know if
you guys know but there was a bunch of
what they were him for six games it's
not a new franchise it's actually been
around for quite a while since 1998 an 8
98 98 when the first Rainbow six came
out I remember getting this on that
became a Don on PC is what I played it
on it was subsequently added a bunch of
weird consoles in the Dreamcast actually
the year later and it is natural home
it's like so different when you think of
it like Rainbow six now like the
original now in comparison to what like
sieges it was this crazy like tactical
plotting where you're gonna send people
like you put them outside doors and then
have like like shortcuts to say like
alright go now yeah and then like the
god look at these graphics like thing I
remember like if there was a line of
sight with the enemies they would like
murder you instantly yeah like one
bullet down and it was really hard I
remember playing the first game look I
got sure huh and they have the same
death animation she did anyway that
always like just fall over backwards
like bend their knees and fall backwards
so she was so I mean destructibility
with these let's work dole where it all
started that I had a serious flashback
just looking at the like gems and
geometric shapes on those diagrams man
cuz yeah it was so tight it was so about
that kind of planning and that like
setting up your AI friends to like go
like know when they would go to this go
point and I think that's a lot of like
we're seeing some backlash against siege
because it is such a divergence from
this kind of very measured tactical
situation not that you know
the stutes kind of running around going
a bit ball Timmy FFC does end up
including terrorist hunt you'll have
some of this in it yeah I mean that's a
good point we're only really looking at
one mode it may be the marquee mode for
siege but there is gonna be solo play
there was gonna be co-op play we just
don't know anything about it yet and the
next game came out in a series which for
me was the high point which some people
say isn't part of Rainbow six Canon is
rogue spear how is it not part of
rainbows right so yeah I know some
people don't think Advanced Warfighter
or Worf
yeah warfighter not warfare it was as
well but yeah rogue spirit came out a
year later look at ding chavez right
there that looks familiar this exchange
yeah pretty much we just played all
morning and this was less kind of them
this was more outdoor areas I remember a
lot of others were looking at the
airplane siege here right now and it was
way cooler they had like bunch more
weapons bunch more ads like variety in
terms of the enemies and whatnot like
the weapons they had and it was super
cool that's it this is like my favorite
one that was great sniping in this as
well like going through forests and
using camouflage and like sniping people
out from pretty far away interesting
yeah that's I mean that kind of playing
around with the size of space and
certainly not the direction that Rainbow
six is currently going I love airplanes
in video games they've always got so
much goddamn space like woefully
inaccurate yeah the presidential plane
and siege is massive Spacey yeah there
was a bunch of expansion packs for this
on for Rainbow six but then I guess
frame was six three Raven shield came
out in 2003 that was okay that was a big
hit on consoles it was an Xbox version
PlayStation 2 version but then the sort
of the next big flash point which is
where one of your favorite games in 2006
with Rainbow Six Vegas and it's
interesting you talk about the backlash
to siege because there was a backlash to
Vegas as well it ended up being pretty
great but at the time people were like
this isn't the Rainbow six game I mean
you can make the argument that that's
kind of when things started getting
people say console eyes yeah you know
started making the game more friendly a
little bit less hostile of the players
you know that was a period in time where
developers started wanting players to
get through their games it was like
changing philosophy it was like we'll
make it hard but we'll make sure that
you can get there
whereas I think before that they're like
aw screw you if you're not good enough
you don't you don't make it totally I
know six is Vegas and I think it was
2008 when in Vegas two came out yeah
they were like they weren't just
straight-up first-person shooters there
was a bunch of like tactics but like
looking underneath the doors and like
setting up your your plays and also like
it was rolling your fingers around in
circles and also you could die pretty
easily in this as well not as bad as the
original number six or rogue spear but
you're pretty vulnerable in this one I
came from Vegas or Vegas too though
we're also I think you could you know
you could spot the bad guys and then
tell your team when to go mm it's weird
because you know in siege you kind of
need to be able to do that but without
anybody being the designated team leader
and everybody just sort of doing their
own thing sometimes it feels like they
need to actually take some of the things
from Vegas and figure out how to
encourage people in multiplayer to play
that way I mean I think for me the
biggest impact of Vegas I didn't play it
a whole lot but what I just heard about
it so often from this cadres of people
that would play it with their two or
three friends yeah like regularly they
just run it so often and and they like
just that kind of tight-knit team
tactics like moving in concert with each
other covering the angles like that that
kind of intensity really appealed to
folks and really hit home yeah big
multiplayer component in this bad boy
and you're right like it that's staying
power the people who enjoy playing it
kept playing it and Rainbow six Patriots
it was another one that was around for a
while which then eventually got canned
yeah yeah yeah it was a trailer and sort
of I wonder if much of this and ended up
being in siege actually and do you guys
play Advanced Warfighter at all which
isn't I guess Rainbow six technically
like Ghost Recon Advanced Warfighter
I think oh I think I got into Gras but
that was after the Advanced Warfighter
it was a more as a future soldier oh god
I forgot about Dodge yeah there was
those were some of the games that I
thought looked the best on that it was
like early 360 like gameplay of the
stuff like I was one with the sink
shooting oh yeah why that was future
soldiers yeah yeah it was like three
bullets at once yeah done yeah that was
a neat mechanic I thought like you could
use scout with a drone
you spot them and assign each roles and
then you could do that in like Splinter
Cell Conviction as a one dude you didn't
need all your used to try and be able to
do that in the first frame for a six
game where you'd you'd set up these like
calls you'd like you'd shoot and hit
like page up and like end and something
else to like make those teams go alive
as well because they've been like docile
mode and then like within three seconds
eight if your team would be [ __ ] dead
like some guide run around the corner
and throw grenades just because you
didn't have enough finger dexterity to
hit all of the keys at the same time
when the one that have had to dumb down
the console versions you know there's
buttons to play with a last note on
siege obviously you guys played a couple
of weeks ago you played some more today
on the stream we're giving out a bunch
of codes in just a minute as well for
our people to get involved in the closed
alpha do you like guys like the
direction it's going in what does it
feel like does it feel like something
that'll like replace battlefield for you
or like a replace evolve for you what do
you think I think it's very
complementary to a game like Battlefield
you know battlefield has been
continually pulled towards Call of Duty
and I'd like I think we need other games
that are pulled back more in the
tactical direction so yeah it's much
faster pace than people are used to in
that franchise but like just bringing
that level of moment to moment like the
tactical illness of it is very second to
second where I thinking very quickly
with your tools on your toes and then
just remembering you can go through half
the crap and that combined to me is is
compelling like they could leave
graphics behind I really care that much
and it's so like that speed it's really
hard to sort of communicate outside of
actually playing it how much cuz you've
got you know you're 40 you're 30 seconds
of prep time and you you have three
minutes for a round it don't sound that
short we're like I don't know if it's
short but it's just like you can burn 45
seconds just getting into the plane if
you're not coordinated you can you can
like the time becomes a factor so
quickly it's just this condensed sort of
loop of tactics adapting trying to get
into adapting firing maybe fleeing but
dying I don't it you know like and that
loop varies very slightly each time but
there's so many variables in there
that's so far like at the
end-of-round I'm still like one more
actually yes another one yes not only
with two maps as well at the moment yeah
well you guys been playing it if you
want to play it at home we've got a
bunch of codes to give away courtesy of
the folks at Ubisoft if you want to get
into this closed alpha there you go
information right there follow and
retweet GameSpot where with the hashtag
Rainbow six siege and that's currently
been tweeted out by GameSpot accounts or
futures make sure if following us
retweet that and then we can send you
the code via the direct messaging system
they're on Twitter do that hammer do
quick that games out like it's Tony and
I think Golf is close it's only week
three week and what Monday yes and yeah
it's only until Monday cool also brush
up on your French just sweetly keep blue
I'm sure that means same reach this door
now sure that's something useful like
that absolutely yeah that's exactly than
me